so
now we're starting virtue ethics again
we did virtue ethics with plato
um but you notice we didn't spend that
much time on the virtue ethics part of
plato
we actually explored um some alternative
moral theories like
egoism and contract hearing and then
finally revealed his hand
and we talked about those those four
virtues the cardinal purchase
with the aristotle we're going to go
much more into depth on
this topic of virtue we're not going to
talk
that much about virtue itself today
we're going to do a lot of big picture
things why does virtue matter
and how do we get to caring about it how
and think back to the beginning of the
semester
we we talked about this guy mcintyre
remember the plain person's
moral philosophy reading um
what themes do you remember from that
what are you
what can you like put on the table right
off the top of your head
about about the macintyre
that's kind of a sign where you've
assimilated it or not
yeah the whole idea of like
everyone has their own story kind of
feeling i remember
we're all within our own story our
stories overlap to some
extent and our stories are not radically
different from each other insofar as
we're all
human beings right so your story is
similar to her story
similar to my story i'm just further
along in my story
as you guys are but it there should be
some commonalities
and those are stories that have to do
with our choices
you know there come points where if you
go this way
your life is going to look like this if
you go this way your life is going to
look
quite a bit different you have to choose
between different goods
how you value them where you put them in
a sort of
priority
your story can include successes or
failures you might feel regret later on
about parts of your story
you may feel elation about parts of your
story
and your story intersects with other
peoples
and affects other peoples
what were the key things the stories
were about if you had to pick
one central idea
yeah it's about like finding your own
good
i guess that was the whole uh idea and
you do that through like you know the
actions and choices that you make
like you were and hopefully learning
about from the effects of that yeah
that was his major point that he felt
like a big part of his uh paper on
in regards to how continuously making
the wrong decision will actually like
lead you down a long path as possible
it'll
actually make it harder for you to
recognize bad decisions as bad decisions
and conversely making the right decision
will
this is why the virtues come in will
help you recognize
the rightness of the decision which
isn't always apparent to you while
you're doing it
and he talked about asking questions and
you could ask questions in very
particular ways
or general ways and one of those
questions is
what is good so each one of you
would ask yourself in the course of your
story and you've done this many times in
your life
what is my good what is the good for me
right and that ties in with these
questions that i've got here
about happiness that i want you to think
about because we're going to we're going
to talk about these
a little bit later on your actual
personal examples
when you think of happiness for you what
do you think it consists of each one of
you
has a conception of happiness has a
conception of
the good life has a conception of what
is good for you
uh and it's motivating you right it has
doesn't motivate you
haven't even changed your mind the court
you know maybe in college or
back in high school about precisely what
you thought happiness consisted of
i know i did a couple times
what will make you happy that's another
way to think of this
what is it going to take for you to be
happy because you're probably not
entirely fulfilled perfectly happy right
now are you
is anybody here absolutely they're all
done
they've reached the end point this is as
good as it's ever going to get
i was yes to say this is it if
that's the case then i think you've
missed the point of being in college
right
this is this is a you're not supposed to
stay here the rest of your life
so i don't know that they would let you
my mom did something kind of similar
actually towards the end of her life she
started working for a vernal college
as a secretary and then worked her way
up and became the secretary to the dean
and she took classes because you know if
you go to if you're working for a
college you can usually take
classes for for a year for cheap and she
almost earned a degree
and then she took a new job at marquette
university
and none of those college none of those
credits transferred because alberto
doesn't have grades
it's one of those pass fail bit
touchy-feely kind of kind of schools
and so she started again and she
actually built up enough credits to
graduate
and this is going to sound very strange
to someone you know she did
she would get close to graduating and
then she would change her major
so that she wouldn't graduate with
whatever this was
because now she needed you know like
four more classes in this major
by the time that she died back in
the term the actual eternal millennium
when she died she had something like 150
credits
so well more than she actually needed to
graduate she was just taking classes
who knows how many she would have
actually succeeded in in
doing it wasn't she wasn't interested in
actually
finishing it she was interested in
taking classes and learning about that
and that can that can become an
objective that can become what motivates
you
hopefully all of you are going to get
out of here first and then maybe figure
out that that's what motivates you
what kind of life is going to make you
happy
presumably you're not living that fully
enough that some parts of your life
fit into that right are any of you
perfectly unhappy i hope not
you have some parts of your life that
that are what you want to keep and then
there's other parts you want to add
is that does that sound right so
aristotle would have something to say
about that
mcintyre has something to say about that
you have to figure out for yourself in
your story
what is your good what is happiness and
you're helped by looking at more general
treatments of that what is the good for
human beings because you're a human
being
but you're going to have to find some
way to make this general answer
fit into your life
and there's no hard and fast rules about
how to do that that's going to take some
some thinking on your part and some
sort of reflection and experience oh
actually some trial and error
i would say um
now aristotle is going to start this
this book by talking about
something else something not quite
connected to happiness immediately but
it's going to lead us there
so it says every art and every inquiry
similarly every action in pursuit is
thought to aim at some good
for this reason the good has rightly
been declared to be that at which all
things
aim so you know what is the good
what is your good it you can tell what
your good is by looking at what you're
aiming at doing
what the i put it this way what the
purposes and points
are of the things that you do and you
look at other
people this way too this is how you made
sense of the world when you were a kid
and started figuring out why people act
the way they do which
you probably was kind of a mystery an
enigma
at least it probably still is for some
people why they behave the way they do
there's some point to what they're doing
there's some purpose behind what they're
doing
so i actually want to linger on this
this
this passage which is a very famous
passage for just a couple minutes
it says every art now do you think by
that he means
just painting drawing music drama
things like that what do you think he
means
this is art the greek word
is uh a bit broader
yeah like for you your art would be
teaching
or something else there might be
yeah another way of thinking about every
discipline
it's kind of funny that you say that
because i don't usually think of myself
i think of myself as a philosopher
and then as a philosopher who teaches
but yeah i suppose
how i earned my money and what good i
actually do as a philosopher is largely
through
through teaching so maybe that's my
prime purpose yeah
based on that statement like every art i
thought like
plato kind of already covered it when we
were reading like about how his creation
of his city
how he was talking about people having
their particular
position yeah each profession having its
position
in a society and if they strive each
profession strives for its own good and
doesn't yes
cole mingle will have a perfect city is
what he was
saying you're right he's talking about
arts in the same
broad sense there you can think of it as
each
each profession anything that you could
come up with a better and a worse way of
doing it
so farming for example you know is
farming just a matter of going around
and just throwing the seeds wherever you
like and then just hanging out for a
while
and coming around picking the stuff up
and taking it to the market
there's a lot more involvement it isn't
there you actually have to know like
when to plant the things some people
probably have gotten um
frustrated recently because it's been so
nice out right
when are you supposed to plant things
around here
anybody know the rule of thumb
yeah and when does that usually happen
like now like marjish no
we we had frost last night we got down
to 28.
i guess you never know i thought it was
like lately for me
what's that late april night yeah about
that for this for this region and you're
a little bit warmer than what i'm used
to i'm used to like
people actually planting after memorial
day because you know from
the more continental climate north
you guys have the sea and the hudson to
even things out a bit people started
planting things
over this last weekend because it's been
so balmy for so long
well a lot of those things aren't going
to survive because this week is going to
be cold cold cold cold so even if they
survived last night they may not survive
the next day
and the art of farming would tell you
probably shouldn't do that you should
actually like
you know follow some sort of progression
there you know there's things you
shouldn't plant next to each other
because they'll screw each other up
um again the discipline wouldn't tell
you that
um every one of you has a major right
every one of you has an art in what
aristotle says
so you can you know arrange it different
ways like criminal justice how would you
define
the purpose of criminal justice what's
the overarching goal
what do you think i guess
i've never had to answer that question
before this is something you should
think
and like uh law
and i mean there's different ways to do
it whether it's law enforcement or
yeah they're different justice wise like
in reports
there are different functions and you
might say that criminal justice is not
just one art but a bunch of arts
all put together maybe to protect
society
what about accounting what's what's the
purpose
it's basically uh operating a business
properly
so that you actually know how much money
you get
without it we wouldn't be able to have
the size of businesses that we have now
i mean you could go beyond a mom and pop
store basically
and without without the kind of
accounting that we have you also
couldn't have a credit system
that we all rely on i mean you can think
about this for any one of your majors
there's a
a why to it an overarching why
you may not have talked about this in
your classes it may just be sort of
assumed
while you're here we're going to teach
you this stuff you'll figure out what
you're going to do with it later on
but there's always a lie there's always
a purpose and a point to any of the
things that you're doing
likewise in inquiry he talks about any
inquiry
let's put aside academics for the time
being because you know every one of your
majors is a form of inquiry
what else are you curious about what
else
do you research we're not even
necessarily researching what do you go
on google
and look up because all of you do
right what is it you want to know about
somebody in the last class said
celebrities i think a lot of people do
okay it's why they're celebrities why
their twitter accounts are huge compared
to other people's twitter accounts
if you ask them why do you why are you
looking at so and so is paige
because i want to know about them that's
an answer that's a
purpose what else do you guys want to
know about
yeah i i'm into like gadgets and
technologies
uh like i always like look up like tech
news websites i think there's a lot of
people who are interested
too right yeah
okay yeah that's that's that's a good
idea too
um people do that with movies they do
that with
music what else do we look at
that's new that's coming up some people
do with cars
yeah and and that's a really easy thing
to answer why are you doing that because
you'd actually like to watch them
at the right time right when the season
is going on for
for uh the nfl i'm on the espn site
looking to see you know who's injured
who's not that sort of thing i'm
interested
yeah i feel like i just googled like
three or four just common knowledge
questions
yeah we do that as sort of a go-to now
and here's a dirty secret a lot of
academics
no problem using wikipedia they'll tell
you you can't use it at all
but they have no problem going through
because it's usually the first site that
pops up
the funny thing is when you type in like
how do you do xyz on google
and it's got all those suggestions some
of those are really off the wall
and there's comedy sites that are
devoted to it i like actually going on
to comedy websites because i like to
to laugh so there's certain cartoons
that i like to
to check up on you know that they have a
new um
this one or that one if you ask me why
because i enjoy laughing
yeah um just like looking at like
internships and stuff
oh yeah now we're getting more serious
stuff right
uh and that's important for
anything that you're you're studying and
you could god forbid this should ever
happen to you but
let's say you hire a private eye because
you're worried that your spouse is
cheating on you or something like that
that's an inquiry that's trying to
figure something out and if you if you
ask that person why did you give them
500 bucks or a thousand bucks or
i don't know what it is because i'm just
going to my movies you know
they can say i want to know about this
i suspect this there's a lot of serious
things that we want to know about
and they're all purpose-driven they all
have a point to them
every action he says everything that we
do
in my last class i talked about when i
at the moment that i started
bringing this up i had a pen in my hand
and i was kind of you know twirling it
around
i said why am i doing that who knows
i don't know why i pick up objects that
are in front of me and you know
kind of gesture with them i think it
probably makes me feel more comfortable
at the
lectern to do that there's probably
something having to do with you know the
need to keep my hands busy
but that's an explanation isn't it it
might not be a great one
and sometimes the the answer to the why
is i just wanted to do that
if you're walking down the hall of
whistling and i come up to you and i say
every action has a purpose what's the
purpose of your whistling
you might just say to me whoa back off
dr sadler i don't know
i'm just whistling i like to whistle and
that would be a perfectly
legitimate answer according to aristotle
there's some activities like he says
where the activity itself is the purpose
and then there's other activities that
are supposed to produce something and
this is what we call ends and means
there are some activities that are ends
in themselves they are we've used this
term before
uh intrinsic goods for that person so if
i enjoy whistling as i'm walking down
the hall and there's no actual point to
my doing it
it's its own end pretty trivial thing
there's other things that we uh do you
have a question yeah what about like
reasons for not oh that would that would
fit the same
uh sort of thing you could look at not
doing something
as itself its own kind of action like um
why don't i swear at you guys you know
something i don't
do i've got some reasons for not doing
that
right for keeping the language clean and
also not you know
making you uncomfortable or
what else would go along with it i mean
i can think of lots of reasons i think
it's a bad pedagogical practice
i've known some professors who do and i
i didn't like seeing them do it um
i think it tends to alienate the
students
would you guys feel uncomfortable if i
started swearing at you
we would just assume you're really angry
at us
how would now make you feel yeah well i
don't know about that i have a teacher
that swears who doesn't swear at us but
he just kind of like makes it like a
like i have one teacher also who doesn't
like accept any
non-educational like language you know
where like
the teacher that swears kind of makes
you feel like they're treating you like
adults more than the teacher that wants
you to speak like adults you know
because kind of being more informal
makes it kind of easier in the classroom
okay you wouldn't like my sword hatching
no
no no i don't think i'd like it with
anybody
no matter what okay so that would be an
example of not
doing something and there's purposes
behind that as well
right
not taking the opportunity to sleep in
this morning
and to choose instead to come to class
you can look at those as
sort of two sides of the same coin you
chose not to do this
but to do this instead so you
chose one thing over another
not swearing at you doesn't mean that i
don't do anything i
speak in other ways right hopefully i
have a happy medium between
how did you put it requiring students to
talk like adults or speak like adults
being very formal and then being very
informal hopefully
somewhere in the middle there
so everything that we do we can ask
what's the goal behind what's the
purpose behind it
why is this going on and we can we can
ask
further and further questions we can set
up chains of this kind of thing
let's look at a couple examples
just hypothetical examples to illustrate
this
something that i think a lot of you have
got to do
and all of you will eventually have to
do buying a car
right how many of you have have bought a
car
so far good about a third of the class
um
is there anything that you need to do
before you buy a car or you just walk
out of the lot and
take the first one
either that or have a lot of cash right
unfortunately not too many of us have
that
myself what else do you need to do yeah
research yeah that's pretty important
so maybe you read consumer reports or
you know a car
magazine has your license oh
yeah you know that that one is probably
the first one
um yeah
that's that's right you do have to have
a license
yeah i mean you don't want to walk on
them a lot and you
actually at your age want a two-door
you know something small and then
somebody sells you on a minivan
because unless you have a whole bunch of
kids a minivan probably isn't that
useful
when you have to pack equipment or
something yes i was gonna say like
monetarily
like us we're probably gonna go to like
a uh
uh not like a lexus dealership or a
mercedes dealership we're going to go
like that i don't think i'll ever go to
like a student yeah like a honda again
okay so figuring out where to go yeah
that's that's
that's a good one too i mean you could
go to the jaguar dealership just to look
yeah i mean they won't sell you anything
anyway
well most of the fancy dealerships
charge like a fee for test driving
yeah wow that's good to know
okay so now why do you want a car
why do you want to buy a car let's
assume you actually do you don't want to
just lease a car
drive somebody else's car yeah somewhere
around will be easier
you need mobility and what do you need
mobility for
okay this one is going to have
multiple purposes you need to be able to
get to work
school school so that one will be kind
of temporary
um i suppose unless you have kids then
you have to drive to school
something like that or some of you may
be perpetual students who knows
you don't seem excited at that prospect
uh anything else yeah see your friends
okay um
okay before we get too complicated with
this let's
let's look at this now we've got a whole
chain already you know we do
you want this somebody sees you reading
consumer reports
and they say why are you doing that well
i want to buy a car why do you want to
buy a car
well i need to get around we don't
usually say mobility's safe but you know
he said i need to get around right
and then they say what do you have to
get around for well i got a job to go to
i have to get to school or i want to be
able to go see my family who live in
you know somewhere other than
poughkeepsie right
walking distance because even if it
kicks you probably won't have a car
wouldn't you
to get some places um and you can ask
further about these well why
why do these matter why do you want to
work
some people you know they say yeah
you're right why do i want to work and
then they quit working i'm not saying
why are they asking so many questions
well okay that's a fair question
um because sometimes it's like the kids
just you know say
yeah three year old four-year-old saying
why why why there's these kids that live
down the street from me and every time i
come home and they ask me if i'm finally
done at college
and i tell them no i'm like well go to
school
why i
what they're doing is they're figuring
out the
the structure of the world there's a
phase that children go through
you notice the why question is not a
what question it's it's a question about
ends and means about the purposes of
doing things
and they're very frustration they're
very frustrating because they just keep
it up
and eventually you get to the point
where you say well this is this is the
end this is where i'm trying to get to
and for aristotle ultimately all these
things would have to do with happiness
you want to work so you can make money
but why do you want to make money
so you can be happy right why
do you want to hang out with your
friends and family that's not a
no-brainer some people hate their
their family some people actually don't
seem to have friends that are really
friendly
why do you want to hang out with them
because they make you happy in some way
right
maybe they do so by giving you pleasure
maybe they give you things that you like
but why do you care about that because
it'll make you happy
eventually so that's why we're asking
these questions
because ultimately we want to see that
this whole change
everything that we do is organized
eventually to lead us to what we
conceive of as happiness
let's take something really trivial
so one of the things that i did at the
beginning of the semester
was talk about learning outcomes you
guys remember that
this notion of
learning outcomes ring a bell
we're gonna just say ah that's that's
that's stuff for the professors i don't
need to worry about
every syllabus here at marist is
supposed to have learning outcomes
spelled out again
apparently not all of them necessarily
do very clearly
but that's what's supposed to be the
case and you can say well why
why have learning outcomes i mean
learning outcomes by themselves
are a kind of spelling out of
purposes they tell you why are we doing
all this stuff
what's the point of this class what
should you be getting out of this
if you know if you put in sort of like a
contract you put in your amount of work
if i set up the class right and i'm
doing my job you ought to come out of
here and know this thing and be able to
do this thing
and have some grasp of this and you know
i spelled them on the syllabus
we talked about a little bit of these
they are
ends they are goals for for me and for
you
perhaps more for me than necessarily for
you
i sort of you know set things up to try
to get you to end up
doing them but i think some of you when
you read through them you're like yeah i
want that out of a course
those of you who are who are paying for
your own education out of your own
pocket
probably looked at those learning
outcomes and you said i better get this
out of the course or dr sandler is going
to you know
be on my on my bad list um
why do you think we do these things we
talk about
some reason going beyond just the
learning outcomes for actually having
learning notes
for spelling them out
i mean we could just say well you know
we're supposed to learn a bit in this
class
some philosophy stuff
that's my goal for you my aspiration
something along those lines
what is it about the act of actually
putting them down on paper
and putting them in front of you and
also
giving it to my dean what's important
about that
yeah it's almost like you're um setting
the standard or expectations both for
like you to us as students
but also for you to your team
that you know you're saying like i
expect
i think that's a good way to quit making
expectations clear that that's a
reason for having learning outcomes
i think you're right about that now why
would we want to make expectations clear
notice we can ask another why question
what's important about that
yeah okay so
let's put it as this getting a
clearer idea of where to go
you're a lot more likely to actually
wind up where you want to be
if you know where you're going on the
map right
you just get in your car and start
driving picking the roads at random
uh where you well have any of you ever
done that
a few of you where do you have enough
typically
yeah well first you get lost i think if
you're where actually am i
then you really need the map don't you
thank god enough for
gps's because back in the old days
they'd have a paper map and try to
figure out
how did i get to where i am what can i
recognize
you have a lot better chance of
developing as a student if you have some
idea of what the goals are
you know when you're studying um and you
start feeling
a bit stressed because you have to study
so many different things and you have to
start making cuts
well am i going to study this thing what
am i going to pay attention to
if you have some idea of what the most
important activities are
you're much more likely to succeed
aren't you
there could be some other goals too
there doesn't always have to be just one
goal
i can tell you another important goal is
accountability
if i actually have learning outcomes
then other people can have clear
expectations of me
and the whole process of this school
providing you college credits depends
these days
on the expectations being clear and the
school demonstrating that people have
actually
met or surpassed those expectations not
just you guys but us
us professors that's how they can tell
whether we're doing our jobs or not
it's not just those student evaluations
that we give you that you know you guys
fill in the bubbles and then you know
they go over to the dean's office or
something some other place i'm not quite
sure where and we get the results like
three months later you know they want to
see that we're actually teaching you
what the class is supposed to be
teaching you so
if i if i set up an ethics class what do
you think some of the things
this class really really want to cover
should be
if you had to pick just one thing that
you think this class should accomplish
what would you say
yeah learning the different moral
theories
i think that's pretty good if you guys
get out of this class
and a month from now
somebody comes up on you to you on the
street and says
uh do you know anything about kant he's
can't who since then either i didn't do
my job or you didn't do your job right
something went wrong somewhere
if you can't tell me the difference by
the end of the semester not right now
necessarily by the end of the semester
between virtue ethics and deontology and
utilitarianism
somebody somebody screwed up because
that's a really important part of the
class
um is it nice to be entertaining
to have interesting examples that's
that's probably helpful but those are
more
things along the way right
accountability would be a matter of you
actually coming away with the knowledge
that you're supposed to have
so that's one good example let's think
about an even broader example having to
do with education
why did you come here to marist
why aren't you just in the workforce
hanging out at home i mean your answer
might be mom dad and let me
but then you can ask why not right so
let's call this
going to and staying here because
anybody can go to college
as you all know staying in college is
not quite the same thing as going to
college right
there's a lot of activities that are
demanded of you
you guys been putting in a lot of work
over the last three years
four years for a few of you what's the
whole purpose of this why why are you
doing it
why are you putting yourself through
this showing up here at eight o'clock in
the morning each which you know tuesday
and friday
yeah so you get a degree and get a good
job
okay so you're already filling in a lot
of this
graduates get a degree
and for most college students um at
least most of the ones i've ever taught
i suppose there's some people who are
independently wealthy and
they don't need a job but most of us
need jobs right
one of the main reasons for going to
college is to get that degree
and then that gets you a good job
now is that necessarily guaranteed not
in our economy
and when i taught this material not nick
mccain ethics but i taught this
this sort of problem-solving thing in
critical thinking classes
at my last university where the
graduation rate was about seven percent
the four-year graduation rate and they
were taking in
um students with very very low sat
scores it was a
a sort of bottom tier institution trying
to serve those who otherwise
wouldn't have gone to college almost all
of them were first generation college
they had the idea that well i just got
to get to college
and then things will take care of
themselves and then i'm going to have a
good job
and i would point out to them what
actually gets you that good job
and then you know the smarter ones
because there's always like a
talented tent would say something like
having
skills or you know having what employers
want and employers you know you guys
know this employers aren't going to hire
you just if you have a college degree
what else are you guys doing along the
way that's that's hedging your bets yeah
good grades that's important right um
just skating by with a the lowest grade
point average
probably is not going to be that good
what else do employers really care about
though
building a resume to show your
attributes yeah that's really important
building a resume
it's tougher to do while you're a
college student i think because
you're spending most your time in the
classroom or you know
studying but you can in fact do a lot of
activities
what's probably the most important one
the most important thing that you do
that employers they can easily identify
that is
hey that that's something that we shows
us that this person could be a good
candidate yeah
i think you're right an internship is
probably
one of the best ways to show an employer
that first of all you're committed to
things
and that you've got some real world
experience
and so you know the transition here
is not automatic but you can do a lot of
things along the way
if this is really what you desire you
probably will do those things
back here won't you this is just sort of
a pipe dream
you know sort of a hazy objective
that would be nice if you get to but
it's not really
you know something that you have a lot
of drive or passion of fire force
then you're probably not going to do an
awful lot on this end
i had students who would actually think
literally
that just showing up to college and
staying in college meant that they were
going to be doctors lawyers
pick whatever you want you know i put up
to them
you know if you want to go to law school
and you're getting
c's in your classes right now you know
one you know
critical thinking one-on-one that's not
going to cut it
those are a lot tougher classes you have
to build
skills along the way so if you actually
want to make this progression
you do have to have some clear idea of
where you want to go the purpose
but you also have to think about a lot
of nitty gritty
nuts and bolts things about how you move
from here to here
to here and then i think you should
think about this
this question why do you want to get a
good job
not everybody does not all of your peers
do
right do you think you probably know
some people from high school who are
going to work at the car wash the rest
of
their life i know i didn't i know some
people
in my high school did i think they
thought i was one of those people when i
was in high school
i had no intention of going to college
why do you want to get a good job
yeah most of the time you have a
lifestyle in mind
and you okay good job depending on i
guess like happiness and how much money
lifestyle will make you happy
and again i think this is one of those
cases where
people very often think so much about
this
they don't put a lot of thought into
what kind of lifestyle will actually
make them happy they figure if i can get
the good job it'll it'll
work itself out that's not necessarily
so
because you've seen people i think who
have what we call midlife crises
what does it have a midlife crisis if
you had to
boil it down for somebody
what is that like yeah
you're just not happy yeah
uh that's a good way to put it realizing
in the middle of your life that you're
just not happy
and probably you've done all this other
stuff right and then we throw in a lot
of other things too that
what people think is going to make them
happy
getting a good house
marriage quite often or maybe a you know
a very enjoyable lifestyle without
without a spouse or kids or things like
that
and then something comes along and it
usually happens
at the midpoint of somebody's life
that's that's why we call it a midlife
crisis but it could happen
earlier it could happen later and
they realize i'm not actually here i've
missed my goal
i thought i had my goal but now that you
pull the
curtain back things aren't as good as i
thought they were
i'm not being fulfilled i'm not actually
happy
and then you know it helps to trace back
what was the purpose of doing this
why did i do this and you can also ask
okay if i want this
what do i need to do in order to get it
that's carrying out means and
reasoning
i'm not going to bring up any more
examples because when i'm
on time you can think of a lot of other
examples of these and this is a good
segue into
this question of happiness
aristotle says everybody is seeking
happiness but there's different
conceptions
not everybody sees it as consisting in
the same thing
and if you think of some really skewed
understandings of happiness
understandings that i don't think that
you share
what would some of those be
what are some things that seem to be
aimed at by people
that they seem to think will make them
happy
but you think it's just completely
screwed up
you don't have to necessarily think of a
real life person you think of people in
movies or
yeah growers yeah you know
there's that commercial it's an old one
now
where this it says nobody actually likes
says i want to be a junkie
i'm going to start out being a junkie
but people do get into drugs
a lot of people do and why do they keep
doing the drugs
yeah i mean that's that becomes their
conception of happiness
it may be that they can't imagine
anything else you know
one reason why why some drugs are so
addictive is because they provide
pleasure in a very unmixed form
like heroin for example that's why
people do heroin i mean after you get
hooked on it you got to do it because
otherwise you go through horrible
withdrawals right
but the original reason why people start
doing it and then keep doing it again
is because it feels so good same thing
with a crack
other you know opiates connected with
heroin
um
i mean drinking is kind of like that
except it doesn't provide those of those
sorts of eyes but i don't know this from
experience i notice from having lots of
friends and relatives who've used
hard drugs yeah it's it's just instant
gratification it's gratification
yeah and for some people that is their
vision of happiness
you know you could have the the
gratification the pleasure the
fulfillment
right away without having to do any of
this other stuff like hold down a job or
you know maintain a marriage or go to
school or anything like that
is a conception of happiness it
understands happiness
as just pleasure and it would be a
particular kind of hedonism right
epicurus wouldn't say
go out and do heroin right but your
stimus might
you know or imagine this here's a here's
a thought experiment
imagine we're not using drugs now but
you know you've got this pleasure center
in your brain
that's part of what drugs stimulate
other things stimulated too
having sex achieving some sort of
victory
those those are pleasant what if you
could put electrodes into that
part of your brain and just stimulate it
directly
there's actually a science fiction book
which begins with that premise
and these people of course they quit
doing anything so they go into this
machine
electrodes go into their brain it ties
in with pleasure centers directly
and of course what happens to their
bodies they get very flabby because
they're not exercising at all
and they just stay there the rest of
their lives
now if pleasure is really what your goal
is
you know somebody offered that to you
shouldn't you take it
and that would be it if pleasure is the
be
all and end at all then if you have the
chance for that kind of machine
jump right in because you're not going
to find anything
so unmixed as far as pleasures
unless maybe you think mental pleasures
matter right
are there any other conceptions of the
good life that you think are
like terribly flawed the person who gets
themselves hooked on drugs
there's something wrong there
what about the safest oh it's going to
say
like people that have like a lot of
material possessions
is perceived as a good life but a lot of
times
they like suffer like psychological
effects from it like later on in the
midlife crisis they're people that live
their lives based on material things
yeah if if the whole thing that you
center your life around is accumulating
material things
it could be money or could just be a
bunch of toys or you know
fancy houses or stuff like that you're
probably
setting yourself up late on when you go
through some sort of crisis of
meaning to have what we call a mid-life
crisis
and why do we call midlife crisis
because they can happen at any time they
can happen in your
20s they could have them in your 60s
most often they happen to people about
my age
middle life and usually because
some priorities have changed the kids
have left
or it won't happen to me because i had
my kids later but
change jobs relationships change and now
suddenly things don't make sense anymore
what
what somebody thought was making them
happy turned out to not actually be
making them
as happy as they they believed
themselves i would say like
that happens to a lot of people like
especially like
i know in the profession i'm going into
like when you first get into it
they want you like usually 60 to 80 hour
work weeks yeah you know i mean and to
become
a partner you pretty much have to
dedicate
close to that amount of time for like 10
12 years
yeah potentially so you get to the point
where you're just working
to acquire things or reach like a goal
but you're actually
never benefiting from what you're
earning
until you make perfect right right but
then again you just
spent 12 years you know of your life not
really
enjoying yourself yeah and you have to
when people do that they do that because
they're making some sort of trade-off
they think that the ultimate goal is
going to
be better than what they're giving up in
the short term right
and it could turn out that that's the
case or they may get to the end and say
crap this was not what i wanted
i thought this was what i was looking
for but it turns out it's not
yeah i feel like in that way that's more
seeing it as a means to an end
instead of as a purpose not like okay
if you're saying you're going to spend a
year
60 hours of work a week
12 years and you're saying you're not
enjoying it
you're not getting anything out of it
you're just doing it yeah
or what goes along with that is another
way of describing is that's the purpose
of all that end and purpose are more or
less the same
concept and i mean hopefully it wouldn't
be better if
you really enjoyed all that work on the
way to it that would be a better life
but people do sacrifice a lot sometimes
to try to get a big payoff
you know aristotle says in your notices
and you look at the nick of mccain
ethics he doesn't consider every
possible understanding of happiness he
says
some are so far along we're not even
going to bother with them
but think for example about about a
sadist somebody who
enjoys hurting other people right
um they have some conception of
happiness
it's not a conception that we would
think is is on track
and it seems to be one that has to be
constantly fed doesn't it
hurt somebody that's not going to tie
them over for too long maybe find
somebody else to hurt
people are motivated that way though
aren't they some people are
made that way and so there are a lot of
varied conceptions of happiness
what are some of your conceptions what
are what are some of the things that
you think the good life for you
your answers to that question what is
that going to look like
the last class came up with about eight
or nine different
things a lot of people could relate to
the different answers
so what will make you happy yeah
okay i think that's an important one the
other class
interestingly enough didn't come up with
that per se
that's a really common answer
every placement i've taught that's one
of the first answers that comes up
yeah like reaching my career goals and
like
um having a good marriage okay
let's put those two very separate things
right
actually let's include what do you think
do you think the reaching career goals
could be under being successful or is
that something different
i think being successful is really
really broad because you could say being
successful
in like being successful being a mother
or like a wife
or oh okay in your job so being
successful abroad
yeah i guess myself this might just be
an example of
my own makeup i always assume being
successful means like a career
think that being successful reaching
like nirvana
okay so what did you mean by
being successful i was thinking more
than professionally
okay so let's specify that as a
professional
career and then you you said um
marriage success what does success in
marriage look like
we know what failure looks like it's
worse right
uh that's one clear feeling there's
other ways to fail still staying married
just um being happy and
like unconditional love for your spouse
okay so
both people happy
unconditional
between the two people um anything else
you want to put in or we can come back
and specify more
what else do you want to make you happy
again i was just gonna specify something
really quick for that
marriage yeah uh the idea of
understanding that you know
there are gonna be bumps in the road
because
most people like i mean you see a high
rate
of divorce in this country it's because
you know people don't understand that
a marriage is a very it's not a fairy
tale basically
yeah i mean the key things that people
tend to argue about are not the ones
that you'd originally think they would
like you know
when you see people say finances are one
of the biggest things people argue about
marriage you're like
if that's not going to be me you know i
wouldn't argue with somebody about money
i'd argue about other stuff or i
wouldn't argue with them at all
but then you get into it and then you
realize yeah there's there's reasons
for these trends that that is something
that we tend to do
and so you've got to be able to figure
out how to get past
that and actually it's interesting
there's this researcher out there who i
don't actually buy a lot of his his
stuff but he's
he's uh
apparently he's very good at marriage
counseling i'm blanking on his name
right now
he's got a lot of marriage books out and
the one thing that he says that's the
best predictor of whether
a couple in crisis are going to survive
or not as a couple
is whether they um show contempt
towards each other or not so you know
when you disagree
do you disagree in such a way as you say
you are so full of it
you know like that that is that the
attitude that's probably not going to
work then
even if you manage to stay together do
you want to be in a relationship where
somebody's talking to you that way
characteristically
certainly i can have any unconditional
love in that case
what else what other other things that
you want i think on
getting our good job valuable okay
um
good job what goes into a good job for
you what are you looking for
something that you like to enjoy doing
because you don't want to go to work
every day
and just be like miserable yeah
um anything else
say again vacation
um we're making good money
i mean there's there's plenty of jobs
out there where you can do something
that you enjoy doing but they're not
going to pay an awful lot to do it
wouldn't it be better to get paid to do
what you like to do
vacation is important right
i don't know if you guys you guys have
probably heard these stats you know we
start out usually
like one or two weeks of vacation at a
job
europeans who have a different way of
looking at jobs like
five weeks usually five weeks
um we professors we get a lot of
vacation so we don't get paid for it
so more like being laid off yeah
we're temporarily yeah it's sort of like
sort of like being
um a trades person
except you got no unemployment you know
for that time
and they say they're paying you over a
certain
period well so we get
jobs that's a big part of our lives uh
being successful in general
marriage what else are our
components of happiness
so how does that fit in with happiness
and complications um
why else do we want to be good people
why why else do we get a charge on that
yeah
i think those are too too um connected
with different things aren't they too
um so feeling
good about myself being able to look at
oneself
and say yeah i do feel like i'm a good
person i like this person that i'm
looking at in the mirror
as opposed to you know avoiding the
mirror and then you said
something about other people wasn't
helping other people was it
does it feel good to help other people
sometimes it feels bad
doesn't it you don't like them but
sometimes it does feel good
yeah it can make you feel appreciated or
they won't respect it okay um
let's put that as a separate thing
appreciated
or respect um
i think that is a an important part of
happiness for
for most of us isn't it i mean would you
be content to
have lots and lots of money that have
everybody just like you
can you be happy in a condition like
that
some people think they could because
they go for that
but you know it doesn't seem like that
would really be a very happy life right
this is probably enough to work with
right now so
notice what's what's not up here and i
pointed this out with the other class as
well
nobody said i just want to have a life
of enjoying myself
constantly
you know doing anything that i want
whenever i want to
the life of pleasure and aristotle talks
about that is one of the candidates
listening
for happiness he says many think that
uh the good life the life of happiness
is just a life of pleasure
he brings up this guy sergeant hopkins
sardianopolis was a
rich king and so you know if you're the
king everybody does what you want
and you can enjoy any sort of indulgence
or any sort of
uh pleasure that you want to
so you know wine women and song or
playstation or
what else do we what else do we take
pleasures in
watching sports
what about a life that just consisted in
one continuous round of pleasure
none of you said that i think that's
kind of interesting
because every other place that i've
taught that came up like
first success would come up usually
after that
and actually the other thing that would
come up usually before success
being filthy rich i wanna i wanna have
as much money as possible
uh i just wanna have as much stuff
and you know once one second
because i want to follow through on this
i think that that's
um i think that that's sort of endemic
to our society and it's not just our
society it was common in aristotle's
time as well
and you see it in a lot of societies and
one of the things that's kind of
interesting to think about
why you as marist students don't
sort of meet the norm of saying i want
to be filthy rich
i want as many pleasures as possible and
i want to
be a big success in business as just the
only things that you want
that's something interesting to think
about yeah we might
as you know reflect the goals in life
but this is just the foundation to get
there i feel like almost
you know when you retire all these
things marriage maybe
yeah you can pretty much get there
say that one more time so if all this is
your foundation yeah once you retire
yeah you know i even thought about it
this way before
um but you could think about what
aristotle was saying in terms of
retirement
when people retire
sometimes they die right away and very
often when that's the case it's because
their job was the center of their life
and they didn't have anything
else that made them happy
people who actually flourish them after
they retire start doing new things
they learn an instrument they start
volunteering and things like that
what motivates them to do that you know
by that time you're
you're pretty set in your ways you know
by the time you're 65
actually i won't retire until i'm 75
probably i don't know if any of you will
actually retire by the way give them
current
current trends so it may not be an issue
for the rest of us but those who retire
who do
well and seem to be the happiest are the
people who you're right have this stuff
as a basis
and then they're able to end yeah i
think
like a lot of us believe that
for instance you said none of us chose
to have one continuous
pleasure yeah i think that isn't a
reality for any of us
for especially in our generation nothing
keeps its luster like everything loses
its luster after a while
no pleasure i can't think of a pleasure
for myself that i could have
like every single day that i wouldn't
eventually
i need to change it up a little bit
that's interesting
um i think like nothing in excess is
something that
for us is important because as soon as
we
like you said the people that flourish
are the ones that don't
go by that they don't want to change
what they do
and they don't continue using the same
pleasures
i mean some people do seem to think they
can go from pleasure to play with the
pleasure and just keep throwing more
stuff
in there
that's a really interesting thing to say
you know it's
if you do have that notion and you get
it early on that
merely pleasant things aren't going to
satisfy you
you're set for your life
in a way that i know i wasn't for mine
when i was when i was your age
you're further along the spectrum of
maturity
ethically not just in terms of like
emotional injury but in terms of
yeah i agree that it's like unachievable
because
there's so many other factors like
people depending on you and like
sacrifices you need to make
yeah you can't have like all pleasure
with basically having relationships with
other people
yeah and you know something else that
came up in the other class was
most likely you guys have experienced
a lot of good relationships and so you
actually know what the value of those
are if you if you came from an
environment where you really had no
experience with good or like think about
marriage where
all married people you know are
miserable you probably wouldn't put that
up on the list would you
that's part of the stuff that makes you
happy
and you can only put up so many things
everybody has to pick something
so if you don't have if you can't
recognize these things as genuine goods
you have to find some other goods to
shove in there and you know
to satisfy and
you know it may not be as satisfying
aristotle talks about wealth and we'll
we'll get to well think in just a minute
because i want to
look at some of the things that he's
saying he also talks about pleasure and
we just talked about that
what about honor aristotle says that
some people pursue
the life of honor and they think that's
going to make them happy and having a
big name having positions having people
look up to them
and that's kind of like this feeling
appreciated or feeling respected
aristotle says that's closer to
a fuller conception of happiness but
it's still not complete
why not well
it's dependent on other people
um have you ever done good things and
not been appreciated for them
have you ever had people do good things
for you and then you didn't say thank
you
as a kid probably right um
i don't have to go quite so far back
myself i had still problems with that in
adult life
um this is dependent on on other people
why do you want to feel appreciated or
respected do you just want to feel
appreciated or respected
no matter what i mean there's just
people out there who are complete
dirtbags
and they seem to be motivated just
driven
by the need for other people's approval
and it's very hard to approve of them
because they're
you're doing terrible things right but
they're not good people you're like
oh i don't want to be around you um
we do watch them sometimes on reality tv
but would you actually want to be
neighbors with uh
some of the people on reality tv
maybe a few of them but probably not
most of them would you be roommates with
them
what do we want to be appreciated or
respected for
yeah for like oh
well basically like the work that you do
like in your place of employment you
want to be appreciated
for what you accomplished there yeah
so that's wonderful right
what you bring to the table we say
absolutely and also like i feel like
people also want to be appreciated
strictly based on their
companionship too too like if i'm
if you're my friend i would like you
to appreciate me as a person that is
your friend
rather than for anything else that may
come out of it
yeah that's an important distinction
there later on in the semester we're
going to look at aristotle's views on
friendship and he talks about you know
being friends with somebody just for
what they give you
and being friends with somebody because
you actually appreciate who they are
and there's some people who it's tough
to be friends with for who they are
because
you don't like them actually you like
what they give you because they're not
nice people
you know there are some people who are
genuinely unlikable
um i think within all of us
aristotle's points out when we want to
be honored we want to be honored
or respected or people have affection
towards us or things like that
for the sake of our good qualities not
just for what we like you said not just
for what we put on the table
but for who we are you know
we want that to be appreciated as well
we also want to be appreciated
and actually known as who we are
that's part of happiness for aristotle
but
what leads beyond this this is where we
get to the being a good person
part aristotle says that what's really
going to make us
most happy is
virtue having good qualities
good good good character traits working
on ourselves to make ourselves better
better persons people will appreciate us
hopefully although you know sometimes
you don't get appreciated for being
virtuous
if you are virtuous you will actually
have a pleasant life too because
for the virtuous person the person who
is actually virtuous
doing the right thing they like that
that's how you can tell whether you're
really virtuous in respect or not
like for instance when it comes to
generosity the really generous person
enjoys giving to other people
the person who is not stingy that's the
vice
the person who's stingy hates giving to
other people right it hurts them
to give things away and then there's
people like like me
in between who i give things away
um but i don't always feel good about it
sometimes i'm you know giving stuff away
and i'm like
man i really would rather hold on to
that
but you know so and so needs it so
i can go without those those those
lattes
whatever it is that we're accumulating
but i'm not completely virtuous yet
because i don't actually take pleasure
in that virtuous activity
but i do recognize that's the right
thing to do
the virtuous person the person who
actually has virtue
developed within their soul they will
feel pleasure that is a pleasant life
so all the good things that flow into
happiness
tie in with virtuous activity it's a
it's a fuller
conception of the good for you you might
say it has to do with
what it is not just to to get what you
want but to flourish
to open up as a person to develop who
you are meant to be
that's what virtue is for aristotle
and you exercise in a lot of different
ways some virtues have to do with you
know
what do you do when you get angry with
people that there's a virtue associated
with that
do you give things to other people or
not are you a good friend
are you fair with other people these are
all things having to do with
different ways of being a good person
right
and that's what virtue ethics is going
to focus
so let me ask you then these questions
what would make you happy if you had to
pick one or two things
that are really central for you
what makes you happy as a person
it can vary from person to person being
surrounded by people i enjoy
okay um
i like that notion of being surrounded
um
let's put that being
not just having a few relationships
right being surrounded
by people
i think that's a big one how many how
many of the rest of you can relate to
that
you know almost everybody in the class
um what else what else makes you happy
yeah giving back that's an interesting
one too
um giving
yeah what do you mean better i don't
like the last portion
okay so
that's a very mature thing to say i
don't usually get that from
college classes i think maybe going here
has something to do with that
marist is very oriented towards social
responsibility
what else yeah i know for me personally
i really want to have kids one day
okay
uh raising them is a whole different
different ball game
anything else involved with this notion
of
you want to put marriage in there too
with the kids or
sure marriage
family
what else now start getting a bit more
greedy or egocentric
yeah let's say like um in terms of like
kids and giving back and stuff needs to
be like financially stable in order to
do all these things
that's a good point um
stability um
or security like we often say um
yeah that's an interesting one um
free time or
do you often call this would i be
leisure is it right or is it
okay leisure for uh let's call it
activities
doing what you would like to do maybe
it's fishing i know i enjoyed
you know actually having enough time to
fish and i haven't fished for a long
time because i don't have much time
i like reading other people have
different hobbies right
playing music through you can you can
tell how
you can tell whether i'm i've arranged
my time
well by how much time i actually get to
practice with instruments
i don't get any time to practice with
instruments it's because i haven't
arranged my time to have any leisure
because that always comes last in the
day you might say
what else do we like to do what else is
part of the
good life for us yeah um
okay let's call that a lasting
positive
influence or effect
on people that's an interesting one too
very surprised nobody's said anything
like having a good time
you know enjoying myself to the utmost
having a
life of uh wine women and song or you
know if
you're attracted otherwise just wine men
and so on right
or beer man
aristotle thinks that some of these are
important components of happiness
and i think arizona would actually be
pretty impressed by this class
interestingly now um are there any
others
that you think are important that we've
left off
anyone no
okay so aristotle talks about
different kinds of lives lessons and
they all depend on
what people think happiness consistent
so if you think that happiness is
fundamentally
being surrounded by people that you
enjoy that's compatible with
but it's not exactly the same thing as
say giving back or helping others
in need or say a life that's devoted
specifically to circles think about
mother teresa for example or a lot of
other religious
they live lives that are devoted to
service they don't have much of their
own do they and they often have to leave
behind
family although they often gain another
kind of family
in the process
those are very robust notions of what
happiness
or the good life would consist in and if
your life
is fundamentally oriented by being
surrounded by people
who you enjoy that's going to be quite a
different life
than a life that's fundamentally
oriented by
just making a lot of money isn't it
there's choices that you'll make
inevitably along the way where you have
to choose between this good and this
good
i mean if it was a perfect world you
wouldn't have to choose between goods
but it's not a perfect world
and you do have to make a lot of choices
a life of pleasure is one that in
aristotle's time
a lot of people thought happiness
consisted so
you know having as many parties as
possible
getting to do whatever you like whenever
you like think about the life that
if you want to think about celebrities
think about the life that some
celebrities lead
weird hedonistic lifestyle
do you think a lot of people in our
society think that happiness
consists in pleasure as well probably
how come you guys don't i mean
this is the only place that i've ever
taught where students
the first answer is not something like
making a lot of money
or having a good time
what do you why do you think that you
guys as marist students
come up with all this other stuff
instead which is great
any idea
yeah um maybe because
it's a lot harder to make a lot of money
whereas uh i'm not giving back so you're
not
to reach happiness
that's i that's again something i've
never heard anybody
uh say either although you're quite
right that's true
a lot of people think that it's
it's easier to just pursue pleasure or
pursue
wealth than to um
devote yourself into service to other
people they don't realize how easy it
actually is
or you know to be surrounded by people
that you love you don't have to have a
lot of money for that
that doesn't take an awful lot of
resources does it
you got to be kind of the kind of person
that people want to be with
that's kind of demanding sometimes
yeah that's an interesting point too
aristotle says that in order to do
ethics well
it really helps to have had the right
outbreak
and i think part of this is
having had full experience of some of
these goods
you know some people haven't really
experienced what it's like to be
surrounded by
friends family who they really get along
with some people
you know say what you went to a high
school that's very cliquish
you didn't mesh with anybody
you didn't have a circle of friends that
you fit in with the people that you did
hang out with were all ripping on each
other all the time it would be harder to
to conceive of this though right if
you've never actually experienced this
or
let's say you come from a family where
people hate each other
i've seen families like that that would
also make it harder i think to do that
or you know some people would say giving
back to other people screw that
i'm going to get what i can get maybe
that's in part because they've never
actually tried it out
you guys presumably can relate to this
because you've actually done some of
this and you've seen what the effects
are and you know what it feels like for
you
probably you've experienced some other
people giving to you right
from time to time when you didn't
necessarily deserve it or you were in
need
yeah um
free time or leisure for activities i
think a lot of people can relate to that
the more pressed you are for time the
more this becomes
something that you conceive of as being
happy so for some people
just getting on vacation you know not
having to show up for work
for one day would actually make them a
bit happier
this is a really interesting one too
having lasting positive
influence or effect on people and i
think that one ties in a little bit
better
with what aristotle was talking about is
another
component of happiness honored and
one of the things that aristotle says
he's talking about pleasure he says the
life of pleasure is kind of slavish
we're gonna we're gonna put that aside a
lot of people buy into that
but that can't really be the good life
what about the life of honor the life
uh where you're acknowledged for your
your
good deeds for your what you've done
your legacy sometimes we say right
what about that he says well that's a
little bit incomplete too
in part because you're looking for
something from other people
to give to you pleasure is very passive
you're looking for things to give you
pleasure right honor you're looking for
people to give you something because of
who you are
what you earn so it's more about you
but you're still dependent on other
people so what if
you do good things but nobody recognizes
it
that that could fit in with what you're
talking about
because not everybody does get
recognized for the lasting
effects or influences that they have so
i think what you're talking about is a
little bit more
like what aerosol is calling virtue
um virtually we've talked about this
before it's good states of character
good states of who you are they're part
of the fabric of your being the opposite
is
what virtue another
v word vice right and those are bad
states of character those would actually
cut you off from
a lot of these these things
having a legacy is in large part i think
gonna be a product of developing certain
character traits
uh so is i think so does giving back too
actually for that matter you can't just
you can't sustain that without having
some good character traits that are
going to be required
especially the more you give having
raising kids being surrounded by people
that you love that's probably going to
involve virtue to some extent too
because you know why would people want
to be around you if you don't have any
good character traits
unless you're just making them happy and
then having kids
will demand of you of certain virtues if
you're going to raise the kids well
being hairy is going to demand
eventually if you summon some virtues
because otherwise you're going to stray
you know so aristotle says that
a lot of these would fit into
aristotle's conception of happiness he
doesn't spell them out like that because
he's much more concerned
in this book to to show that it's
not pleasure it's not wealth it's not
honored by itself it's virtue virtuous
activity
that leads to happiness that's the
fullest expression of happiness
you know does he does he think that the
the person who has pleasure isn't happy
at all
no but it's not a full conception of
happiness like
this stuff would be how many of you can
get behind this
if this is the composite picture
for this class how many of you can like
look at this and say
yeah this is this is a good picture of
where i want to be
20 years from now or for the rest of my
life can everybody
anybody object to this say this stuff
isn't for me
does anybody think anything really
critical has been left out
this is actually a pretty good composite
picture i think of what aristotle's
talking about
what he's bringing to the table is an
emphasis on the need for the virtues
and he's going to tell us what virtue
looks like
and how to cultivate virtue
so good exercise
there are some people
for whom this is the central value right
you may know some i'm guessing you
probably do right
uh what do we mean by wealth it could be
money it could be property
it could be just you know material goods
put somewhere it could be stocks you
know imaginary things stocks are really
imaginary yeah just throw this out there
because this is going to be on youtube
you're missing it now
on
now i know why nobody said yeah i
recognize that right away
okay so so uh well
aristotle thinks that there's a lot of
ways in which people
get mixed up about this they don't
realize that wealth is
merely an instrumental good that's
supposed to
ultimately provide us what we need
for happiness
and you know there's a lot of things
that you have to do in order to
put next one to try to get wealth
right there's means that lead to wealth
like saving money
if you don't spend your money as much
you'll be you'll be wealthier
or working extra hours or
choosing a profession that's
remunerative as opposed to a profession
that perhaps you love
more the goal of wealth is ultimately to
provide us with happiness by buying us
the things that we need by providing
us a basis and aristotle doesn't say hey
be as poor as you possibly can so long
as you're virtuous
he actually thinks you need to have a
certain level of material
security in order to be truly happy
if you're if you're virtuous you need
some things to do things with
if you want to be a good friend you need
a little money don't you
if you want to give if you want to be
generous to other people
you could give time you could get energy
but it also helps have a bit of money
and some resources
there's a lot of other things along
these lines if you have a
you know modicum of wealth you're going
to be a lot less tempted to do
unjust things to earn money that you
need to survive
aristotle also thinks that you need
friends and family
so you have to have enough wealth to
interact with friends and family he
doesn't think that
the happy person is completely isolated
by themselves he thinks that the happy
person
is in a matrix with their friends and
family
but quite often people get mixed up
about this
and they they forget what the whole
point of the wealth is right
yeah i think people hear love and make
a lot of money and a lot of goods and
stuff like that where
i think the real definition of wealth is
enough to keep you
living yeah like securely you know
where wealth is in extreme
amounts of money and stuff like that
it's enough to keep you going
yeah there's there's a there's two ways
of looking at
wealth or money or property there's a
way that keeps it within certain limits
it says
here's what i need in order to prosper
to do well
and then there's everything else
he talks about this in that section of
the politics that i
i also gave you he says of the art of
acquisition
the art of wealth giving there is one
kind which is by nature part of the
management of the household
so far as the art of household
management was either find ready to
handle itself provide things necessary
to life
so the things that you actually need and
useful for the community
of the family or the state so there are
certain limits though
you don't you don't need 28 cars
right how many cars do you think when
you have a family how many cars do you
think you need
that's probably a good number what about
when your your kids are teenagers
still ages two do you need 30
well you know one maybe one for or how
about twelve one for each one
okay and some people do that right
you know you really like um cadillac's
maybe you should have a red cadillac
for when you're wearing red clothes and
blue cadillac clothes
and or maybe you want to you know mix
and match not a bad idea
so he goes on and he says these are the
elements of true riches
for the amount of property which is
needed for a good life is not
unlimited there's a boundary fixed
just as in the other arts riches may be
defined as a number of instruments to be
used in a household
or a state and then he says there's
another variety of the art of
acquisition which is commonly and
rightly called an
art of wealth giving is in fact
suggested in the notion that riches and
property have no limit
and this reflects that attitude that
sees the good
as well as as property as money
being nearly connected with the
proceeding it's often identified it's
very easy to get mixed up about these
things
but though they are not very different
neither are they the same he says
if you allow yourself to fall into that
is literally a bottomless pit
there's no limit which you could reach
where you say i've earned enough
unless you actually place wealth
in relation to
something else and you say these other
things like say
friendship or
virtue or even
honor unless these take priority over
wealth
the desire for for generating wealth
will be the one that
asserts itself so unless these place
limits
unless these components of happiness say
you've got enough
you've earned enough for you know
doing the things that are going to bring
you the reputation that you want
you know you've got enough to actually
be a good person
you've got enough to have good
relationships
the person will want more and more and
more and in the end what is that going
to do
that's going to end up ruling out
all these other things because they're
just going to keep on
going on with that and the more that
they do it you put it out that advice
tends to blind us so this is where we'll
leave off vice tends to make us morally
blind to the fact that we've missed out
on a lot of other things that would make
us more happy
i think you've seen people like this we
have people like this and you know
movies and
tv shows but i think you've actually
seen real people like this have a chat
aristotle this is a danger in his time
just as much as it is in ours because
these are
constants of human nature we think about
instrumental
goods um eris level doesn't go into this
very much but i think this is something
that our society has become obsessed
about
what does aristotle talk about is the
you know the sort of overarching goals
that people pursue
wealth aristotle does think you need to
have some wealth
right because you can't live a virtuous
life without having some means
it's important to have friends and
family he says that quite clearly
being self-sufficient doesn't mean
you're all by yourself it means you
actually are surrounded by
people who you love and care about um
pleasure honor another thing that he
brings up as a good
is
health now
if you want to be healthy how many of
you want to be healthy
you know not an awful lot you can tell
by looking at me right
because i don't exercise enough if you
want this goal
what do you need to do what are what are
some of the main things that you need to
focus on yeah
yeah diet um
that's a key one for you college
students
most of you don't get enough sleep
period i don't get enough sleep myself
so that's a big component right once you
eat um
how often do you sleep how much you
sleep what else
what else is critical yeah exercise yeah
exercise
um anything else that you have yet to
pick one other thing
it's probably important more important
as you get older
settling alleviate stress oh
okay um let's add that
how do we want to put that reducing
stress
what's one other thing that you need to
do if you want to stay healthy
yeah very good um
well let's put checkups
you know if you you never go to the
doctor
by the time you're 42 you're supposed to
be going pretty regularly
you never go to the doctor and then you
know you've got some sort of problem and
you go in and they say
you got cancer and it spread through
your whole system if we would have
caught this a year ago we could have
done something about it
well you know whose fault was that it's
the person who doesn't actually
they want health but if you want help
these are the
things you need to do now why do we want
health is health
a goal in and of itself i think it is
for some people
i think some people become health
obsessed
and you can tell that they value this
more than other things
because they sacrifice other things to
this
very often they'll sacrifice other
things to
these things like they'll become
obsessed with exercise
and they will lose friendships
or not make time for their spouse or
their kids because they're too obsessed
with exercising
and getting in that that morning workout
or something like that
i'm not knocking exercise by the way i'm
saying exercise is a good thing
but notice a lot of what life consisting
is what we do with the good things
how we value them what is what is health
actually good for
yeah well it allows you to do the things
that
and stay alive long enough to do the
things that will make you happy
so a little bit louder it allows you to
do the things that make you happy
okay so health is something that enables
other activities
it's a it's a condition
if you want to you know if you want to
be able to travel a lot
it really helps to be healthy doesn't it
because if
traveling meeting different people makes
you happy
but you have to spend most of your time
in the hotel room laid up in bed
you're not enjoying much of that good
life being surrounded by the people that
you
love and actually engaging in activities
with them is important
then you probably want to be healthy so
you know when you take all the
kids to the museum you you're not
wheezing as you go up the stairs
you're actually able to do things with
them if playing sports with that is an
important part
you probably need to be healthy too
right
if you want to have that touch football
game before the super bowl
you don't want to be in such bad shape
that when you get knocked down you can't
get back up
and now you know they've got to rush you
to the hospital
even for other things like like making
money
it probably helps to be healthy um
where go ahead i'm just gonna ask does
this include like mental and emotional
health
yeah i i think that would be important
although
for somebody like aristotle we're going
to see this a bit more as we go into
the virtues per se part of what we did
what we nowadays consider to fall within
emotional and mental health aristotle
would say is actually a matter of the
virtues of the vices
or of what we're going to call
self-control and lack of self-control
that we've medicalized some things that
should really be thought of
as moral issues um and aristotle thinks
that the reason
why you should you should care about
these is not just to like do your duty
and to you know be a good person in the
sense of being good for other people
he thinks that you want to be good for
yourself
you you want to figure out what makes
you happy
and how to get there so that you can
actually be happy
i think that's you know really important
so health can get turned into an end in
itself
and then this gets kind of cut off and
these other things can get sacrificed
is a person like that going to be really
happy
any more than a person who gets obsessed
with wealth
what do you think do you know any people
who are
super health obsessed do they appear
happy to you
she like bikes 10 miles in the morning
and goes swimming for six miles and then
she goes to work
and teaches all day and then like bites
during her lunch hour
and like does all this stuff like every
free opportunity she has she's basically
like
exercising whatever she's very fit she
seems happy
um
yeah it would probably be a person who's
managed to reconcile
health with these other goods where
it's a matter of harmonizing them
together you can imagine somebody like
that and give it just a couple twists
and it could it could become something
a situation where they're less happy
like think about the kids for example if
having kids is important to you and
raising them well
you have to cut up some time from all
the things you like to do
that's just inevitable that's the way it
goes
when you have kids you have less time
for for other things
so if developing a good relationship
with the kids
would be precluded by too much of an
emphasis on
exercise or diet i mean some people
actually make their kids eat a lot of
weird things too because
you know if they're on this particular
diet their kid's going to be on that
diet
might not be good for kids
what else can we become a little bit
excessive about
um aristotle also thinks about honor
can you think of anybody in your
experience who's
so obsessed with how people think about
them that they
leave out the other things that would
make them happy that would lead to a
happy life
we probably can um aristotle thinks
these are mistakes
and these are mistakes to go back to the
mcintyre thing these are mistakes in
asking and answering the question what
is my good
there's all these possible things you
can put on the line
and
why do we actually pursue them for
happiness sake
and if you think that happiness is just
health or
money or honor then you're going to stop
short aristotle would say
instead for aerosol we want to realize
that eventually this is this will
involve being healthy and this will
involve pleasure
and this will involve having resources
and this will involve friends and family
but what's really going to be central to
this is going to be
virtue and not just having virtue
but virtuous activity a life in which we
actually do things so you know life of
service would fit in with that i think
a life with friends and family would fit
in with that because you're virtuous in
relation to your friends and family
the legacy that you leave behind by
influencing
situations and people for the better
would be an expression of virtue
so virtue and
virtuous activity what this means
this is where i'll leave off we've
looked at a lot of different
alternatives
a lot of different answers to the
question what will make me happy
aristotle would say if you want to be
happy the best thing to aim at is this
the other things um
if they interfere with this if they
stand in the way
if they leave you away from this they're
not actually good things for you
they might be good things in themselves
but they're not necessarily good things
for you
so you have to figure out if you want to
be a virtue ethicist
you have to figure out not just what
what happiness looks like for you
but also what the virtues are going to
look like for you but we're going to
spend
the rest of the next couple weeks doing
that so